silvio berlusconi is used to making
grand appearances this time his
supporters celebrated as though he'd
just won an election in fact the
occasion was a name change Berlusconi's
party is now again called forza italia
or go italy it's the name the group or
when the billionaire businessman first
went into politics in the 1990s
Berlusconi's allies hope the nostalgic
change will give the party a much-needed
boost movie got this the only person who
can save italy is silvio berlusconi
either you like it or not I know how the
media think if we had two more Silvio's
we would be the top nation in the world
such bold words can't hide the fact that
Berlusconi is fighting for his political
survival the 77 year old was convicted
of tax fraud this summer on the 27th of
November the Senate will vote whether to
strip him of his seat as a consequence
in recent months Berlusconi has pushed
his party to break away from prime
minister Enrico letta's coalition
government instead it's the party that
has ended up breaking apart we weren't
and we aren't any longer capable of
bringing down the government despite the
smiling faces it looks like Berlusconi
might have run out of trump cards to
play